ah
it's always a lonely lonely time
when I'm in L.A all by myself
left back for Vegas already because you
know tiger got school so he has to do
the whole school thing mobra went back
with her and uh since this week our JK
Newsweek is pushed back because everyone
has crazy schedules
um I'm just staying like the whole
weekend and today for JK news tomorrow
and every time they leave me I always
feel so lonely and sad it's just me and
this guy right here
remember all the times on like JK news
and the Vlogs I've been talking about
eczema on my balls I finally got a
chance to uh get seen by a dermatologist
so they prescribed me some like mild
steroid and then also to put on this
lotion and I've been putting it on for
about a week now and it feels way better
I'm not scratching my nuts in the middle
of meanings trying to hide myself from
like scratching underneath or anything
like that so my nuts
are in way better shape I have no idea
what it is it could be me moving from LA
to Nevada and Nevada does have a harsher
water so if you are moving from LA to
Nevada make sure you get a water
softener
for me I think almost within the first
two months I realized oh wow the water
here is really harsh but because early
on we already knew we were going to move
out I didn't want to go through the
trouble of installing
a water softener because it's downstairs
where my big ass safe was so I just knew
it was going to be a pain in the ass so
for sure we're getting a water softener
in the new house so
um I probably like after I went off
these steroids I probably should be
completely fine and not have any more of
these weird eczema things because
growing up I never really had eczema
which is really interesting that now as
an adult like certain stimulus I don't
mean my skin got more sensitive or
something but now I do get it from
random stimulus
so before I head out to the office I'm
grabbing my meal
for lunch and yep still on a diet and
yesterday
I meal prepped look at that bam aren't
you guys proud of me really trying to
stick to the diet and not allow myself
any opportunity to make dumb decisions
like order KFC or something like that so
yesterday I made this this is a cup of
rice
some asparagus asparagai how do you say
asparagus and plural asparagus
asparagus is Asperger's and then also
about 60
um
grams of protein right there and I made
four of these
packing the little hanzu
because ponzo a steak almost always
tastes incredible
and uh it's like one of those low
calorie things that's
a little it's a pass to your Pizzazz you
know what I'm talking about
hammer
that's what I said I was like don't
worry Mom I'm a vlog right now because
she hates me the Vlogs she likes her
privacy and I literally just turned the
camera over there she's like you said I
wasn't gonna be in it
good morning shadow Shuttle good morning
oh you're so beautiful you're so
beautiful
he's so beautiful oh I miss dogs good
morning Robert good morning
I usually always do my hair like when
I'm going to the office so it could be
in my work mode you know like I like to
put on my work hat almost as if like uh
you know when you're about to play a
game put your jersey on and that's like
your game day Jersey
but
since it's like a gloomy day
it just made me feel like oh let's be
chill and relax
and maybe also because modern tiger are
in here I just feel like I want to be a
little bit Cozier instead of all like
always feels good to be back in the
barbell office
even though no one's here so I'm still
lonely but there's just something about
an office space and that separation from
uh work and home
that gets your brain like turned on you
know like that's uh one thing I really
learned through like the pandemic you
know when all of us were like working
remote and stuff and working from home
holy moly is 85 Degrees the water is so
hot in here
72 there we go
yeah that's one thing uh that I realized
when we were working from the office
like that extra 30 45 minutes that we
would drive from home to the office
it felt like time wasted you know like
in the first two or three weeks I think
when we uh had um the work from home it
felt like okay cool yeah we wasted so
much time it feels so much productive
working from home but once we started
getting settled in into working from
home then I realized you're not as
productive because you get comfy and in
the lines between work and your life get
blurred almost as if like you know when
you like train with a team at a gym like
a powerlifting team right versus when
you're like I'm gonna just do push-ups
or whatever at home and then the
push-ups turn into I'm gonna watch I'm
gonna do push-ups while watching Ozarks
and then I'm gonna do push-ups while
watching Ozarks and also like uh making
sure I start prepping dinner and put on
my rice cooker and then the intensity is
not there anymore and that's what I
realized it's actually really beneficial
for me
drive for 30 45 minutes get here boom I
got my wolf on wolf on Wall Street on
I'm like ready to rock and roll
[ __ ] and then I could even end
my day early and then go home and then
uh take my hat off and relax versus just
like a big mashed potato mush so even
though no one's here
I feel very productive already
and uh that's my goal right there I'm
gonna get cranking on work for a few
hours and then I'm gonna devour that
steak because it looks delicious
so this is how I like to work to be as
efficient as possible especially when
you get to your desk and there's like
something you're extremely passionate
about right like for me like I'm really
excited about where the direction of the
bottle Brigade apparel is going in the
next couple of months so I can't wait to
work on that because that's design and
it's creative but I know I also have a
bunch of other stuff I have to do
um in the past what I would have done is
just jump straight to dessert and then
boom boom boom boom I spent all this
time on it and then later on I'm done
with it and I zoom out I'm like oh [ __ ]
I only got like an hour or two left and
I have all these other things I have to
do
so
um me being mature mature I guess as a
worker the way that I've moved away from
that so that can be an efficient person
because so many different people rely on
me in barbell Brigade like not only am I
the chief creative director I'm also
Talent I'm also kind of part CFO I also
help like liaison some of the
Departments together so I have a lot of
hats and that's just Barb I also have JK
duties and stuff like that that what I
like to do is when I get to my desk I
spend my first
um like about 30 minutes looking at what
I need to do today what I wasn't able to
tackle last week and I put it all down
on paper even though I already have it
on my like notepad and also on my
calendar and on my to-do's list like my
digital like operating software
there's something that's just so much
more visceral when I write it down so I
wrote down everything that I got due
today before I leave
so from like barbell like even on the IG
like right now I'm technically the
social media manager so we have like the
launch promo also a bunch of dudes been
lifting crazy heavy weights in our new
uh oversized rebirth and BB ethos teas
so I want to shout them out and also
because we have a new launch I want to
make sure to post that on the stories on
my own personal IG we got uh I have to
promote the podcast and also the launch
and also I've been dealing with certain
things with like the veterans so that's
me personally but I gotta make sure I do
that within their time frame because
they don't open 24 hours so I got to
make sure I do that within their like
working window
um also we're working with some like
outside vendors on some really big
things with barbell gotta check up on
that and also our power Builder program
so uh the other coach Jacob
he's bouncing back and forth from the
states to Africa because he helps run
um one of the wall things like biggest
basketball camps and he runs the
strength and conditioning there
so we've been working on the next
program get lean it was such a good
success that um we want to give like
everyone that ran get lean and also
other people that just want to build
muscle and get strong like a follow-up
like what's the sequel thing to do
especially even for myself right like
I'm getting leaner leaner leaner now
it's time to put the muscle back on and
get the strength and put it back on so
we've been working on the power Builder
so I have to see where we're at with
that and we got some really cool
um Squat and deadlift designs that we're
working on if you guys follow the
Barbara Brigade IG and if you don't you
really should because that's where we
put all of our latest updates and stuff
um you guys will remember
that a few weeks ago we posted
uh this this new T right here
right it's like a it's like a squat and
deadlift design so we're really close to
finalizing it and I've been working with
some really sick designers so I gotta
nail that in and also this is the
dessert I was talking about where
planning like barbells
um next to Petal design then I have our
base campings base camp is just like
another like software kind of like slack
or Monday or any of those operating
software that like the entire company is
on and I need to get on there to uh
uh make sure that I give everyone what
they need from me because I get probably
at least 30 pings a day at least at the
minimum and then I gotta plan the JK
cast for this week so this week on JK
news
um I'm really excited because Dante boss
goes back on and also namesh Patel
stand-up comedian thought it was super
funny he saw him on my Explorer Page hit
him up and he was super down to come on
so I'm really excited about that
then finalize some loan stuff with our
new house I came across a new like
mortgage house
a Mortgage Firm and so I just want to
make sure we're getting the best rates
possible and uh
and then also working on our next
collection and apparel and I believe
Geo is calling me so I ended here I'll
call her back and then uh I'll update
you guys once I start get banging on
work
you guys want to see something cool
this distracted me from work but in a
good way so you guys saw a few Vlogs ago
where I went to go check up on my dad's
house and we met up with the landscaper
to kind of like get all the measurements
and see what we can do for the back of
his house
well I met up with more than just one
landscaper and one of them submitted
designs already so I wanted to show you
guys what that dirt lot could actually
end up looking like and it looks really
cool
look at that
so that's that um like back sliding door
when you come out they extended the the
pavers
and they put these little kind of like
barrier walls right so if like kids come
out and play it'll just like run
straight into the tree
and I can see there's a little bit of
turf right there
so they put Turf on that side too right
you can set up like a little picnic
table I like the amount of trees it kind
of breaks up like the boxiness
and that's the other angle
and that's that side Turf area
and that's a top down View
pretty dope right
yeah I'm really happy with it I think my
dad's actually gonna be super happy with
it too because it just looks very
straightforward but not too
straightforward as if like the home
homeowner did it because you know
sometimes when like homeowners do things
because we don't have swag right like
that's not our field like I'm a fitness
guy comedian guy I'm not a landscaper if
I were to go to Home Depot and buy my
own products it's just going to be very
like cut and dry so it's cool that like
they were able to kind of Swag It Out
and like utilize the space and like I
like how the turf is in parallel what
the with the walks and that would make
it look feel very stiff you know they
just kind of swagged it out which is
really cool so I can't wait to send
these to my dad and see what he thinks
back to work look how Kenny this is so
um I was just checking in with Mod bear
because I missed her and then we were
vlogging now in the middle of work
yes you got me six I think you feel
guilty
true
but I still missed you you big balls of
brains
[Music]
what were you doing before flexing
yeah
oh dang look at those abs holy moly
damn I think you're winning to be honest
I better [ __ ] win what playing like
so much
damn
I track it I track my immunity support I
track my my barbell performance screens
my creatine I track all of that even
though it's five calories for everything
combined
I'm still tracking it so I better
[ __ ] quit it's fine
can't believe you got me sick I'm sorry
that's all right well I did test today
and I'm negative
so whatever you have is I don't know
what you have
well it doesn't matter because the CDC
said
that's what they did basically see they
see new guidelines are like
yeah
they're like oh testing
sure
they said you're supposed to help us huh
yeah it says treat it like the flu
which it technically is just a flu or a
cold
yeah hope you feel better mama
thank you you just got me sick and then
you set me on my way the biggest with my
[ __ ] five-year-old son who has
endless amount of energy I know he was
taking care of me he's like I'm Gonna
Get You water are you okay Mom can I get
you anything and then the first thing he
did when he woke up this morning mom how
do you feel
[Music]
I thought he was gonna take care of you
like his style and go like hey Mom let
me know if you need any lollipops okay
because I'll get a bunch of them now you
help me make me make the Theraflu he was
like wait a minute why
okay I can't remember oh that's uni he's
a smart guy
bam lunch time
I'm actually kind of excited for this
because
um
I haven't had steak in a while
because it's actually really hard to
find like super lean steak
with me only having 1900 calories and I
was at Albertsons and they had this
pre-made like sirloin so I was all cool
like not pre-made as in pre-cooked but
like you know the kind that has a
marinade and it's like in back in that
vacuum seal
so I got that made some asparagus
brought some ponzu I always love ponzu
and steak and let's see
mmm smells pretty good yeah this would
be my little lunch
and this bad boy
foreign
excited some of the steak I accidentally
like overcooked like it's like medium
well because I was cooking eight of them
at a time and I kind of lost track and
I'm not familiar with Jill's mom's stove
just yet so I don't know how hot like
her pan gets but it still came out juicy
though
pretty good
hmm
that's the asparagus and thank you
take this back to work
[Applause]
time to go on my midday walk I think I
only have 7 000 steps and it's also good
because ma'am my eyes from staring at
the computer they get tired like they
get they feel like weather so it feels
good to like come out get some sun on my
skin on my face look at like actual
alive things like trees and [ __ ] plants
and [ __ ] you know because I always
figure like we're a biological organism
right so we're born to exist and look at
like biological things because of modern
society like we're stuck in an office
looking at computer screen like 2D
images all the time and we're not
supposed to like our eyes are meant to
like look at this look how beautiful
this is our eyes are meant to look at 3D
images you know we're meant to use our
peripheral vision like we're meant to
like literally look over here and then
see stuff like oh what's going
but we don't we're literally looking at
an image
that looks like this just flat
so I think that's why our eyes get tired
shout outs to The Gamers who could keep
doing it though you know
so I like to come out get my steps in
and I've done a count two now because
before I'll be like walking and I keep
checking my step tracker I'm like wait
did I get enough steps do I get enough
steps so when I hit like a actual good
Pace I found out I can get about a
thousand steps every 10 minutes
so if I like go on a good 30 minute walk
I can hit 3 000 steps and if I only have
time for like 10 or 15 then I can add
like a thousand to 1500 so that way I
don't have to keep checking my watch and
I'll just add in steps
um as needed so for now since I'm at 7
000 I would like to close out the day
already so I'm gonna just hit a quick
30. and then get back to work
all right A little update on what I was
able to get done on my work list task
listing for the day
so I still got to promote one more thing
on the barbell IG at 6 pm and it's 5 30
so it's not time yet but other than that
banged out all these things this I still
got to do and then these two are really
really important so the next time I get
a chance to work I put a star so that I
know to prioritize them and the other
thing that kind of sucks is what's part
of work is as you're working other
things come up so my task list is
growing as I'm banging beans out which
is good because ultimately that means
there's progress right like when you're
like dig through something and more
things surface you're like oh sure gotta
fix that and fix that and fix that so
ultimately
um you're moving in the right direction
even though you're like damn it it seems
like I'll never be done but I got
through most of everything that's really
really important
um the other two things could wait a
little bit so now I'm gonna go home
because I promised Geo's mom
um I was gonna make her some of my warm
hearty yummy noodles because uh
yep as you heard from Geo I got sick
first
and then I got Geo sick and I got Geo's
mom sick so
um I want I need to go back home and
make sure she has a nice hearty soup so
I could take care of her and I'll see
you guys back there
all right now it's time for me to make
my famous
healthy and Hearty egg noodle soup
so I'm starting off by boiling some oh
that's hot some hot water right there
and I'm gonna use this to um make a
chicken broth
and it doubles as two things because one
I'm just gonna boil these chicken thighs
and it's gonna melt all this fat off so
this will be a lean meat after but then
since I'm gonna be boiling uh green
onions a little bit of Ginger some salt
in here this is going to make for really
nice and clean broth so anyone that's
sick it feels very like Reviving you
know then I'm gonna have another pot
which I'll start boiling soon and I'll
put the veggies in there
and the method that I like to do it is I
like to make like a soup concentrate in
here and that's usually like a soy sauce
a little bit of Sesame garlic and ginger
and then I use the soup broth in here
pour it in there and
I tested it and I think I have my recipe
down pat we'll see
oh you see that beautiful mixture right
there
I got Ginger I got garlic got some
sesame oil
got some soy sauce
even got some sriracha
and this might look too flavorful right
now
and it is
because this is gonna be diluted with
this beautiful
uh chicken broth that I'm gonna put in
and it's gonna be so good
all right looks like it's moving and
grooving
get some of this salt action
keep a little salted
a little more
and then
put on some of these green onion stalks
or as they call aromatics
and then okay this Ginger action right
here
[Music]
and mix it all up
get a nice little bath
get ready for a chicken
which is ready right here
this little padding lock
pound of chicken thigh
look at that
here we go
I am
talking about right there
on the light
let's see what we're doing
that looks good
now I'm getting the water started for
the veggies over there
what's really cool with these sliced
Meats which is why you have to go find
them
it Cooks so fast
I had this in here for probably I don't
know like
less than five minutes
and it looks like it's already done
cooking so I'm gonna just wait till it
hits a boil so I know for sure that it's
ready to eat so we don't get salmonella
and then I'll probably pull this meat
out
and then um I'll like pull up some of
these proteins and this broth will be
ready to cook some of the egg noodles in
and I like cooking the egg noodles in
here
because the egg noodles pick up this
flavor and then also you know how like
they like to put a little bit of pasta
water into their dish well I like
getting some of that egg flavor in here
too so
yeah look at that that only looks clean
and good
yep that's ready to pull out
look at all that good stuff
yeah that's the perfect broth right
there
I might just let it simmer for another
minute or two to render more of the fat
off
and pull it out and this
is about ready to receive some veggies I
did throw some salt in here
and this ready
this whole little recipe usually takes
like under 20 minutes
all right in goes the veggies
and by the way bok choy is something
that pairs really well with ginger
takes the ginger is so good
most importantly getting the stalks in
because the leaf Cooks so easily you can
almost just steam the leaf
leave a little room here these guys
try not to make a big mess
love my no promotions
and I pulled the chicken out
now it's time to put the noodles in so
high over here
and then these veggies look about ready
to go gotta cut the leaf
cut it off we'll just keep cooking
little by little on its own and uh time
toss in the noodles
the one on this side
and then I'll put one
on the side
these cook so fast too
all right here's my favorite part time
to take the noodles off
right here
put it into a little sauce we made
there make sure it's not the left
do it again with this
and then we toss them a bit and the
sauce should get like all that goodness
everywhere
smells so good
mm-hmm
this guy
awesome the sauce
then
throw some of this
chicken right here
grandma
's veggies
thank you
I just made properties
okay my second favorite part
okay Mike yours is ready
it's just a verb inside
some green onions on here
bam look at that
look
can you drink some of the soup mice and
see if you like it hope it's good
oh you like it yes ding ding ding so
that's the presentable version this is
the protein pack version because
obviously I'm on a diet got hit my mad
girls but
that's what we got some healthy
soup action heartwarming
and CUNY
all right finishing up
my last batch of macros with a fair life
milk high protein milk and some caramel
rice crackers
and then now I'm gonna go and hang out
with my date which is Jill's mom and
watch some TV see you guys tomorrow good
night